Hello friends I'd love to introduce you
to one of my favorite poy tricks of all
time this is a pendulum it can happen
with our arm extended it can happen with
our arm in one spot it can happen buried
inside of another move it's one of my
very favorite P tricks of all time and
today I want to talk to you about why I
think we underestimate this move and
give you some ideas for how it can help
you out
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're diving into the magical
world of pendulums let's hit it up
together but first up I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys pyro Tera light toys and
Ultra PO for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing companies
in the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-b buus friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission all right so pendulums
needs to be said when I first started
off in the PO World these were kind of
considered to be something along the
lines of the buzs saw where it was like
yeah you know that exists but it's so
simple why would anybody bother playing
playing around with it it wasn't until
i' been spinning for nearly a year that
I finally found an application that
people agreed was cool enough to
actually spend your time on namely the
1.5 or as we called them back then the 1
and a half but I'll be real with you all
as I have grown as a teacher and my
experience as a PO spinner has broadened
I really think that we're
underestimating the utility of these
pendulums so I want to guide you through
several different patterns that I found
over the years that involve the use
pendulums that I think are great for
challenging people at a variety of
different levels from beginner all the
way up to intermediate and advanced and
maybe in the process we'll find a
pattern that is perfectly suited to you
so first up I want to talk about this
pattern right here which looks simple
enough and this is actually a pattern
that I now give each and every beginner
that comes and takes lessons with me
this is just performing what we would
call extend alums that is these big
pendulums wherein we are moving our
hands around in these massive circles in
front of us as though we're performing
either extensions or flowers but instead
we are performing our pendulums as we go
back and forth and of course we can
reverse Direction on the pendulums if we
so choose now what I like about this is
it gets beginners on the right page
sooner rather than later in terms of
taking momentum away from the poy of
course one of those things that happens
early on in our flow Journeys is we're
in this place where we get locked into
spinning the poy at a regular interval
and we don't really have conscious
control over it when we eventually have
to learn how to do things like say
stalls or flowers or the like we're
still kind of locked in that place where
we don't really have conscious control
over how much energy we're putting into
the poy I think that when you start off
performing pendulums it begins to lay
down the groundwork of how much or how
little energy you put into the poy in
order to make them move around in the
way that you want to it also helps that
this is a great exercise for learning
how to switch the direction of the PO
when you want to going around
counterclockwise or going around
clockwise depending upon which side of
this pattern you want to have the POI
lose their energy completely on and then
switch back the opposite way so if
you're just starting off this is one of
those exercises that is going to be
hugely helpful to you for many years
down the line and if you have taken po
lessons from me in any form in the past
year I guarantee you have had to learn
this exercise at some point this is just
a simple exercise for switching back and
forth between different timing and
Direction modes and specifically for
going back and forth between together
same as well as together opposite in
wall plane here um it's also a great
exercise for getting down Independence
between the two hands as you're
performing these pendulums so I usually
like to have people start off just
performing a butterfly and if you don't
know how to perform your butterflies
just yet I will go ahead and include a
link to tutorial on how to do them down
in the description as well as up in the
cards but as you're doing the butterfly
you want to try and do a pendulum
outward with your right hand POI and
then let it fall back into spinning
clockwise along with the left hand so
that they're both spinning clockwise and
together same in wall plane you can then
practice doing an additional pendulum
with the right hand po under underneath
the left and come back around in that
butterfly once again we want to learn
the same exercise with the left hand
doing a pendulum out and then coming
around counterclockwise and then doing a
pendulum under the right hand and coming
back around in a butterfly so we want to
have the ability to do a pendulum out
with the right and a pendulum under with
the right as well as the capacity to do
a pendulum out with the left and then
back under with the left as we go back
and forth here
if you're just starting off and this
feels kind of weird it it does tend to
have that effect on people best way I
can tell you to get this down is
honestly to let the hand that's going to
do the pendulum just kind of stop and
really really really focus on keeping
the other hand going from there you can
think about where's that other hand
going to come back in in order to get to
the part of the pattern that you want to
uh arrive at so again you can do this
both when the right hand goes out as
well as it goes in you want to focus on
keeping the left left hand spinning and
then you can do the same thing with the
left hand letting it go out pause for a
second to keep the right hand spinning
and then let it come back around and
stop going underneath and then bring it
back around in a butterfly ultimately
the presentation of this exercise that I
prefer though is switching off which
hand does the pendulum each time so from
butterfly we do a pendulum out with the
right come around clockwise pendulum out
with the left come around in a reverse
butterfly do a pendulum under with the
right to come around counterclockwise
and we do another pendulum under with
the left to come back to a butterfly
that is
right
left
right left or you can think of it as
butterfly clockwise reverse butterfly
counterclockwise and back to Butterfly
this is one of those exercises that if
you get it in early in your flow Journey
you're going to find that you have so
much control when it comes to timing and
direction
very very early on so it's highly useful
and I would highly recommend you pick it
up and next up I be remiss with any list
of exercises involving pendulums if I
did not include that 1.5 that was so
essential to my own flow Journey when it
came to pendulums 1.5s are soall because
we think of them as being a 1 and 1/2
beat weave based on performing a 3B
weave you bring whichever hand is on the
native side up above the other hand hand
and into a pendulum to essentially uh
pull out of uh one of the Beats of a
weave and thus leave you with one and a
half beats of the weave even though
technically it is still three down beats
but I'm not going to get you that deep
into the theory here it's also just a
really really lovely pattern that allows
you to seamlessly move back and forth
between your three beat weaves as well
as some things that will become more
important later on down the road like
say a split time opposites in spin flow
uh of course to do this you're looking
to work in such a way that you have your
right hand spinning clockwise relative
to you over next to your left hip while
your left hand kind of hangs above it
and as that left hand swings the POI out
in front of you you bring both po to a
stop and then you switch over to having
your left po spin at your right hip
while your right hand performs a
pendulum above it and as they both go
out in front of you boom you let them
both come to a drop so you can think of
this as doing the pendulum once
twice three times and then you switch
sides once twice three times to switch
sides and then you go down to just one
two to switch sides one two to switch
sides and then one one one one the key
here being make make sure that whichever
hand is reaching across your body to
spin the poy is staying down next to
your hips and the hand that is
performing the pendulum has to come up
above your shoulders not only does that
create a much much cleaner shape as
you're going through it but also it
creates that nice little moment where it
looks like the pohe heads are coming
together to kiss on either side all
right so doubtlessly there are some of
you out there that are jonesing for some
more complex patterns so I'll give you a
version of a butterfly 1 .5 that
utilizes some behind the head action
here now note this is really the same
thing as when we're performing uh a
butterfly 1.5 in front of us here and
specifically my hands are moving in a
split opposites uh butterfly uh I would
call this a reverse uh split opposites
butterfly because my right hand is going
around clockwise and my left hand is
going around
counterclockwise and I am going ahead
and having whichever hand and POI are
going across the bottom perform a beat
whereas the hand that's going over top
is just performing a pendulum now in
order to really make this shine you can
go ahead and take that hand that is
reaching over and kind of drape the POI
behind your head like so so it's kind of
traveling from in front of you to drop
back behind your head you're kind of uh
reaching your arm around in like a u
shape so that your hand can drop drop
the poy back behind your head and the
resulting shape looks like this it's a
nice little tweak that you can add to
your butterfly 1.5s to uh give them a
little bit of extra visual flare and
almost bring them into body Tracer
territory here and if you like that well
you ain't seen nothing yet all right so
this next one is a personal favorite and
it involves taking the basic knowledge
behind a tri ketra versus pendulum and
swapping up some of the driving Styles
in it to
uh basically give us some more options
when going back and forth across the top
of this move so let's take a look at it
um the basic elements of this are of
course just a tri ketra versus pendulum
that is um so the tratra is actually a
cap and what we're doing here is we're
trying to get the poad to move straight
up and down our Center Line as it goes
across the top and then we're kind of
taking the bottom of a Box Mode four
pedal anti-spin on the bottom so as the
PO comes straight down you're getting in
these two pedals next to each of your
hip bones like so we want to think
straight up straight down two pedals
straight up straight down two pedals we
of course are going to team this up with
a pendulum keeping our two hands
together because as it turns out the
timing of this is just perfect to be
able to keep the PO moving around in
what looks like split Time same
direction going across the top and
switching into split time opposites on
the bottom
now the real trick of this is that we
can swap out the driving styles on top
so instead of Performing that top part
as what looks like the top part of a
tratra but is actually the top of a
linear isolation we can instead turn
that into a point isolation we can take
that moment where the PO is going up the
center and rather than have it go all
the way up we pause it right about a
body Center and let our hand go up and
over it like so and when we do that
personally I think the way to accompany
that is with the other hand performing a
full extension now the only trick here
is that it makes the trick a little
unstable so I think that it works best
when you're going back and forth between
the two versions of the pattern between
the tri ketra versus the point isolation
but the cool thing about this is that
technically we are also going back and
forth between different varieties of
pendulums because that point isolation
basically has the same characteristics
as a pendulum it just so happens to be
that we have switched up whether it's
the hand or the poy that is uh doing the
majority of the movement going through
it so if you like me find this a
fascinating Twist on an old pattern I
hope that you get a lot of enjoyment out
of it and finally we do have to talk
about pendulums as being an absolutely
essential piece of pretty much any form
of ho stacking there is of course the
butterfly 1.5 that we worked with
earlier wherein we can just kind of
smush it down to being a vertical
pattern like so or we can do the version
that involves us getting these nice
little stalls over to the side where we
have a top stall and a pendulum meeting
together so the difference between these
of course being that when I'm doing my
butterfly 1.5 I am having the PO kind of
switch past each other like so versus if
I'm to add in an extra little beat here
to try and make them meet up together on
either side now regardless of which of
these patterns you you would uh prefer
to
perform uh I think that you get a lot
out of mixing together both the
difficulty of doing these top stalls as
well as the kind of uh the degree of
control that you need in order to
maintain these pendulums and get the two
to match up with each other like so of
course another benefit of getting down
these patterns is that you can take the
top part of them and use it as a moment
to do some float throws like so either
way this is a winner and I highly
recommend
it thank you and hey if you are up for
more pendulum action then you are in
luck because pendulums are the theme for
the flow Circle for the month of October
the flow Circle is a weekly exclusive
lesson that's available only to my
patreon supporters and this month the
theme is pendulums and 1.5s we'll be
covering everything from how to perform
pendulums in different timing and
Direction modes to how to do all the
different 1.5s that I know and some
wonderful exercises that'll help you
master the art of being able to do
transitions with pendulums in all the
different ways you can sign up for the
flow Circle over at
patreon.com drexfactor po the first
lesson is up now and if you got anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel
[Music]
grow this video and all the videos on my
channel would not exist were it not for
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a huge shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you y'all Rock
and if you out there watching would like
to support the work that I do there's an
easy way to do that head on over to
patreon at patreon.com drexfactor poy
and sign up there you can get access to
a whole host of awesome rewards but even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring po spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world so
go check that out please and thank you
and if you want to check out more
pendulum based poy patterns I did an
entire top five list on my favorite po
pendulum patterns that I'll go ahead and
link to down in the description as well
as up on screen and yes I can say that
10 times fast thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace